people think they got you all figured
out based on how you look but that's
simple especially when it comes to me
I'm a little more complex sorry I almost
killed you oh I had the perfect life
until one day all yours little guy
everything changed now I know when you
look at me you think big your ginormous
I can't wait to show you for the rest of
the guys they're gonna fertilize the
yard looks scary young who are you I'm
Oona
I'm dope and then what at all what
happened at race we do not be good you
think someone who can fight I am here to
spectable I'll take that one sucks to be
you I am NOT a fighting bull can you
guys help me out v it's a beautiful
horsey side and sad is this stinky blue
side have a nice day smelling terrible I
hope well
Mina easily I'm getting out of this
place I'm not leaving anyone gone better
plant ever just use exactly what we get
[Music]
exactly as we do
everybody in hit it wait mommy I'm
waiting for that my whole bleep
we got company
great shop through there have you seen
these tips
[Applause]
they're coming we are today I know you
want me you know I look at the cute girl
you